Let's pray together over day 15.
Father, I want to thank you for the holiness that you've gifted to us in
Jesus.
Thank you, Lord, for the will that you have for our lives.
You will that we should be holy. You want and desire
and plan for our holiness, and we thank you for it.
We prepare ourselves, Lord, like Peter commanded us to do, by
getting our minds ready for action, and we want
eyes to see. Like David prayed so many centuries
ago, open our eyes that we may see wonderful
things in your law. Lord, we pray for the
right
mindset, the right set of glasses on our eyes.
Lord, please deliver us from
interpreting the possibilities of
grace through our own weakness.
We're sorry, Lord, for bringing the
possibilities, bringing the standard to which you've called us
down to our own level and limiting God
by my own weakness and my own sin and my own failures.
Instead, Lord, would you help us to interpret our weakness
through the possibilities of your grace?
Would you help us, Lord, to have a heart that rejoices
in possibility when we hear you call us to holiness?
Lord, we choose
to see our own weakness and our own inability
and even our own sin
through the lens of your great infinite grace,
and we ask, Lord, that you fulfill all your promises in our
souls.
Lord, we praise you for the possibilities of grace.
We repent for trusting our weakness more than your strength,
and we ask that you would raise our eyes and help us to catch sight of the
possibilities of grace. In Jesus' name.
Let's continue praying and seeking the Lord together.